no I didn't know I was going to be a
scientist from a young age I I suppose I
was interested in science I can remember
at the age of about six being fascinated
by the planets and learning all about
Mars and Venus and things I wasn't much
of a biologist as a child my father had
been and gave me all the right
influences and my mother too I went into
the biological stream at school pretty
much drifted in I suppose it was about
my best subject but it but it wasn't an
obsession with me like it is with many
bird watchers and bug hunters people
like that
I never really decided that until I was
at Oxford at the age of about 20 I
suppose said it wasn't at school at
school I kind of drifted into the
biology Sixth Form and then I I knew I
was always going to try to get into
Oxford and I did get into Oxford and to
read zoology but I didn't really become
fired up and realized that this is how I
wanted to spend my life until they were
about my second year at Oxford I must've
been about 19
my doctorate my DPhil at Oxford was
about decision-making in animals and I
happened to work with baby chicks but it
could have been anything and I suppose
my first discovery was of a mechanism
that plausibly could be going on inside
the head of a chick or any any other
animal when making a choice between two
alternatives it was not a piece of
neurological research which it might
well have been owned one could have been
looking at cells in the brain and seeing
looking for mechanisms of
decision-making there but my method was
more the blackbox method where you don't
open up the animal at all you watch its
behavior and you develop theoretical
models deduce mathematically predictions
from your theoretical models and then
test those predictions against the facts
do experiments to see whether they're
true and that's a sort of classic
scientific method the black box
technique and I used that and really
rather successfully I developed a model
use some simple algebra to deduce
predictions from the model and then did
experiments which extremely accurately
fulfill those predictions
well my original doctoral research and
I'll talk about something else with my
first wife dr. Marian stamp Dawkins we
worked on what it means to say that an
animal has made a decision if you watch
the muscular movements of an animal are
we working again on on chicks
particularly drinking behavior in chicks
when I when a chick need when any bird
pretty much drinks it puts his bill into
into the water and then it kind of
scoops the water up in the bill and the
rather graceful curve and then the water
kind of trickles down the gullet and
that's a very stereotyped movement we
filmed it
we filmed chick chicks doing this and
then we analyzed the the movement
frame-by-frame our definition of a
decision was based upon the idea that
decisions occur at the beginning of
fixed action patterns which are
sequences of movements which are very
stereotyped and which don't vary so
something like that drinking movement
down into the water and then curve up is
a fixed action pattern once it starts we
conjectured it won't stop so a decision
is the beginning of a fixed action
pattern which determines the next
however many ''tis frames of film on our
frame by frame analysis so if you looked
at the frames of film you could actually
measure and we did this the
predictability of each frame as a
function of the preceding frames we
plotted a graph of the predictability
measured in information theory measured
in bits of information the
predictability of each frame as a
function of the preceding frames and we
found that when the chick began a fixed
action pattern such as drinking the
predictability shot up and stayed up
during the duration of the fixed action
pattern
and then the and then it shot down again
and the behavior became unpredictable
you couldn't tell what was going to
happen next for a while until it entered
another fixed action pattern when the
predictability again shot up this was a
quantitative measure obviously drinking
itself is not a great interest but it's
what is of interest is that you can
quantitatively measure and express what
you mean by a decision in in in a
continuous stream of animal behavior